네 안녕 빌사남 있니다 오늘 촬영할
영상은 4월부터 강남에 급매가 많아질
것으로 예상이 됩니다 그 이유는
[음악]
바로 4월부터 왜 급매가 많아지냐
men 금리가 급격하게 오르게 된게
2022년 하반기입니다 보통 그때
당시에 빌딩 매입할 때 신규법인
설립해서 좀 많이 매입을 했거든요
작년까지 이제 금리가 좀 높다 보니까
2022년 적자 23년 적자가 이번에
나면은 은행에서 부실 징후 기업으로
좀 판단을 합니다 그래서 그 법인세
신고가 올해 3월 달에 있습니다
그래서 4월부터 은행에 이제 전산이
들어갈 예정이고 대출을 연장할 때
일부를 상환하라고 할 수도 있고
아니면 금리가 급격하게 오를 수가
있습니다 제가 봤을 때는 부실 징후
기업이 던지는 매물들이 좀 많아질
것으로 좀 예상이 됩니다 그래서 아마
4월부터 좀 본격적으로 나올 것으로
좀 예상이 되고 지금 좀 현금을
가지고 계신 분들 은 기회를 보셨다가
부실 징후 기업이 던지는 매물들을
잡기에는 되게 좋은 시장 같습니다
하반기에는 어찌됐든 금리가 좀 내려갈
거라는 예상이 많잖아요 지금 담보
대출로 대출을 받으면은 한 4% 정도
금리가 나옵니다 불과 한 1년
전만해도 금리가 제일 높았었던 그래서
그때는 담보 대출로 빌리면 한 6%
진짜 많게는 한 7%지 나왔는데 지금
4% 아지 좀 많이 내려온 상태입니다
근데 은행에서도 지점장님들이
얘기하는게 하반기에는 그거보다 좀
조금 더 내려갈 것 같다 뭐 이런
얘기를 많이 해 주셨는데 아마 제가
예상 컨데 3% 후반에서 4% 초반대
정도 유지하지 않겠나 이렇게 좀
예상을 합니다 그래서 만약에 그렇게
되면은 아무래도 빌딩 거래량은 조금
더 늘어날 것으로 좀 예상이 됩니다
그리고 특히 아까 말씀드렸던 그런
부실 징후 기업이 던지는 매물들을 살
수 있는 기회가 저는 오래 많이
있다라고 좀 생각을 해서 빌딩을
매입하시나요 기업이 던지는 매물들을
좀 본격적으로 보시면 좋을 것
같습니다데 올해 같은 경우 한
1월부터 3월까지 빌딩 거래가 좀
됐어요 그래서 실제로 저희 bsn
거래가 좀 상당히 많이 됐었고 대부분
보면은 진짜 괜찮은 매물 진짜 급매
매물들이 좀 거래가 좀 많이 됐고
그래서 앞으로 좀 이렇게 급매 좀
괜찮은 매물들이 좀 더 시장에 나오고
그런 매물들이 좀 거래가 되지
않을까네 요렇게 예상을 하고 있습니다
그래서 만약에 빌딩 투자를 계획
중이시라면 부실징후 기업을
기억하셨다가 4월부터 좀 이렇게
던지는 매물들을 찾으시면 좋을 것
같습니다 그래서 오늘 영상이 여기까지
하고요 다음 시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다